1976 pas de stylo à la main mais plutôt
une cigarette dès le collège histoire
d'être dans le coup j'ai commencé de
fumée pour faire comme les autres et
ensuite par habitude
maintenant par plaisir en 1976 selon
l'insee 30 % des moins de 17 ans fumer
régulièrement dans le détail 7% chez les
10 12 ans 30% chez les 13-15 ans 54%
chez des 16-17 ans ça fait bientôt cinq
ans et demi que je fais il faut dire
qu'à l'époque fumer c'est non seulement
à la mode
et en plus certains adultes sont
complices par dimanche
évidemment tous ne fume pas d'autant
qu'en 1976 les risques sont connus dans
le dans les poules puis après on a des
concerts par mois des cancers du cas des
cancers cardiovasculaires entre 77 97
les 12 18 ans se détache peu à peu du
tabac près de la moitié des garçons
fumée en 1977
ils n'étaient plus que 23,8 % 1997
quant aux filles la proportion passe de
43 à 26 9% jeune adolescent va devenir
très vite dépendant de sa cigarette
c'est à dire dépendant de la nicotine
dix ans plus tard son tabagisme va être
déjà beaucoup plus importants et avec de
beaucoup plus grande difficulté d'arrêt
des lois des mises en garde
mais il a fallu attendre 2004 pour que
la vente de cigarettes soit interdite
aux moins de 16 ans puis 2010 pour les
mineurs et encore malgré cela voici une
caméra cachée en 2014
depuis 2000 la consommation de tabac
chez les français de 17 ans est étudiée
et c'est très net
la clope n'est plus autant à la mode
qu'ils étaient 41,1 % à fumer
quotidiennement et plus que 25,1 pour
cent en 2010 cette même dynamique pour
ceux qui ont essayé de fumer au moins
une fois qu'ils étaient 77,6 % en 2000
contre 59% en 2017
écoute moi bien christian c'est net et
clair je t'interdis de fumée
[Musique]